I've going to a state for three months where cannabis is legal. At the dispensary I had no idea what to purchase.
What would you recommend for extreme pain? I stopped morphing because it didn't stop the pain and caused nausea and constipation.
The Tylenol and ibuprofen don't stop the pain either.
If you're going to use some sort of cannabis for pain, you really have to go to THC.
The CBD can help with some pain, can help with some anxiety around pain, especially if you're taking a fairly high dose.
I spoke to somebody on the phone the other day that one of their issues was pain and they were taking like 15 milligrams of CBD.
I'm sorry, I didn't get anything. That's not even enough to help with anxiety or help with sleep or anything.
You need to be taken a much higher dose than that. That's CBD.
The THC, I would talk to the person at the dispensary about your condition and let them make a recommendation on the dose of THC.
Not been to a dispensary ever. So I don't know how things are labeled as far as milligram dose.
I think with THC, most of it will start with like a 5 milligram dose and move up from there.
The thing is, whatever you're taking, whether it be a gummy or a product that is like a paste, you will stay longer in your system if you take it with a fact.
So typically in a lot of the dispensaries, you will get THC and you can buy it in a gummy.
It's easy to take because it's in a like a little sugar, you know, sweet tasty gummy because THC kind of has an asher taste to it.
It's a little more expensive that way that sometimes people like taking it that way better.
But that's in a sugar solution. It will, you'll get a spike up THC and then it will dissipate quite quickly.
If you take it with a fact, meaning you could even like, you know, take it with some peanut butter or a big tablespoon of coconut oil, it's going to dissipate much slow much more slowly and it will stay in your system longer.
I'm more in favor of using a drop the dropper bottles of THC, it doesn't have a great flavor, but if you could just deal with that and you could chase it with something pretty easy and you want to make sure you, if you take it on an empty stomach again, you're, it's going to, you know, spike and it might help with the pain, but it will disappear real quick.
If you take it at a full stomach where you've had some fat to eat, it will work more slowly.
Then the nice thing about the dropper is that you can, you can play with your dose and see what you need.
Lots of times of pain you need to just break that pain cycle and then you can kind of stay on top of it.
So you're going to have to play with the dose of how much you'll need the nice thing with a dropper, it's going to be less expensive than getting it in a gummy form and it's going to be easier for you to play with your dose that way.